il a entendu arriver
c'est mélanie très chanceuse j'aurais de
la place cet après midi jeux pourquoi
ben pour te faire une ligature des
trompes dix minutes on pense à cela
c'est une question de
ma ville
[Musique]
stérilisation imposé pour notre
compréhension c'est le fait d'avoir subi
une intervention chirurgicale
qui met à terme le fait de pouvoir avoir
des enfants de manière permanente donc
on impose à une femme un acte médical
pour l'empêcher d'avoir débit bmo moi
j'étais le gars tu les as l'âge de 18
ans moi j'ai pas besoin de réfléchir
parce que j'avais déjà mes contractions
fils
sait quand et à malte et c'est pas le
temps de réfléchir
ils m'ont fait pas parce qu'ils m'ont
dit ce qu'il fait peur des enfants
d'être maître d'être ferme est au pied
du mur n'en concédant plusieurs lieux
délégation des trompes ou maman de
césariennes par exemple et les femmes ne
l'ont pas on ne leur a pas dit qu'on a
procédé également cette intervention
elles vont l'apprendre des années plus
tard et vont se rencontrent un moment
donné que non plus dans un
[Musique]
choc pour moi une certaine période de
temps vont consulter à nouveau leur bon
super disons mais madame vous avez tiga
tuerie déjà quelques années il ce n'est
pas réversible comme comme intervention
donc c'est comme ça plusieurs l'ont
appris
quand j ai vu il dit la fin du dg de
mauvaises nouvelles et jockeys et
d'étapes et de produits
n'étant pas pop et ils l'ont point que
l'épée yao de brûler moi même j'ai
soupçonné ma propre grand mère d'avoir
peut-être été stérilisés dans le cadre
de séjours de quatre ans dans un
sanatorium malgré le jeune âge qu'elle
avait à ce moment là il ne put d'enfants
par la suite
on sait aussi que des femmes ont subi
des pressions pour accepter une ligature
en se faisant dire qu'elle avait trop
d'enfants on assume que les femmes
autochtones
sont irresponsables ont une vie de
travail font trop de bébés donc on est
con on utilise cette fausse impression
là pour les pousser à accepter une
ligature des trompes plein jcb cellules
les amérindiens l'eau qui ont des
enfants non plus finir
[Musique]
j'en parlais seront toutes placées tout
six minutes paraître solo pitt que tu as
des putois les pertes des vins on se
disait que c'est une problématique qui
existent en la grandeur du canada et
aussi dans d'autres pays si on pense
précisément au peuple autochtone et
comment se fait-il que on n'est pas
d'informations sûres sur le guennec
[Musique]
le gouvernement du québec refuse de
s'asseoir à la table nationale je porte
sur le sujet est arrivé sa femme touche
beaucoup parce que je fais partie de ses
gains je me dis pourquoi pas nous
pourtant on est des êtres humains vernis
tout près
pour la première fois c'est une
recherche en est que j'espère en avoir
le moins possible c'est un peu paradoxal
a dit mais c'est ainsi dans ces
situations là où on se retrouve mais ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il ya des
témoignages et que qu'il ya des corps en
fait est que nous n'avons pas encore
terminé
la collecte de témoignages
[Musique]